22 straight years of brutal drought have
just pummeled lake mead one of the
largest reservoirs in the whole world
but to paraphrase mark twain reports of
its death have been greatly exaggerated
marina operators at the lake say bad
publicity has just crippled their bottom
line but as they tell george knapp
they're still open for business
the lake has always been it's either
feast or famine bob gripentog's family
has operated the lake mead marina since
1957 and has learned to roll with
nature's punches in some years the water
level rises for most of the last 22
years it has fallen the massive
reservoir is doing what it was created
to do act as a water bank during dry
years though the driest period in 12
centuries has strenuously tested the
lake's limits this year is definitely
special compared to what it has been
since the early 60s every drop of 40
feet in the water level creates a
thousand feet of beach in front of the
marina so far this year the families had
to move the entire operation further out
into the lake eight times each move cost
around a hundred grand mainly because of
the need to extend lines for power water
sewer and fuel the business has always
been able to absorb the financial hit
because boaters and visitors usually
continue to pour in spend money in the
restaurant and store and launch their
boats but this year is different just
the number of folks that come out to
lake mead internationally wise and and
visit us has gone down
probably 50 percent the reason isn't
hard to identify media coverage has been
relentless the comparative satellite
photos of the shrinking shoreline
stories about bodies found in barrels
the image of a formerly submerged world
war ii era boat now high and dry and the
implication that the lake is suddenly
dangerous because of obstacles lurking
just under the waves all of that
information has convinced potential
visitors that the lake is shut down
the months-long onslaught of negative
media articles both nationally and
internationally have created a false
impression that lake mead has dwindled
down to a deadpool mud puddle but when
you're out here on the water and look
around you can see this is still one
enormous lake those are the stories that
really create us hardships because
people do get the idea that there is no
water here even at these levels we have
over
around 500 miles of shoreline
the water
where we're at right now is over 100
feet deep if you get out into the basin
area it'll be
350 even 400 feet deep gripen talk says
you'd be far more likely to find a dead
body four-wheeling in the desert outside
of las vegas than at the lake and that
the danger of submerged objects is no
greater now than any other time as
always boaters just have to pay
attention it's true that few other
marinas including coalville bay have had
to temporarily suspend boat launches but
marina services remain open including
the slips that house private watercraft
there are fourteen hundred of those
slips at lake mead marina where kids
still feed swarming fish from the dock
and their parents rent boats to cruise a
few miles to check out hoover dam
boat owners usually don't have to wait
more than 20 minutes to get their craft
into the water far different from news
reports saying it takes four hours the
long term scenario for lake mead is
challenging because the overextended
colorado river is the most endangered
river in the country as it has been for
decades but for now and into the future
lake mead is still a premier watery
playground we're open for business we
want you to know that lake meat is still
here george knapp 8 news now